and we are now joined by magnus carlsen
after an
incredible performance today magnus i
mean it could have been
three wins the last one i guess it's a
draw but what are you most happy about
today
yeah obviously in the in the last
last round i had drawn awareness
absolutely equivalent and uh there is
also no rating on
stake so didn't didn't make any any
sense really to
um you know to uh to torture him there
um it's been a pretty consistent theme
i feel uh at least in the in the last
tournament
and and this that i play well on the
first
day uh
i mean i think my my win rate in as
white in the first game must be
must be pretty much pretty high um
and that sort of sets the the
the tone for for the rest of the day
obviously he didn't have his have his
best day and
uh what he did in the in the opening in
the second game was white
it was ambitious but it didn't didn't
really work uh
at all um so
i i don't expect again uh
it to be be quite as comfortable as
as this tomorrow uh but obviously um
it's a great start well definitely and i
have to tell you we have been talking
about i mean we're showing
the mozart of chess game today and we
actually had zipk
ernst here talking about that historical
game and i mean is that the kind of
magic you are showing here in this
tournament so far
um no i don't think so uh
i mean i've spoken about that several
times that that was
that game is massively overrated
[Laughter]
um i i've found a fairly
simple combination there over the board
and that's it really
there wasn't wasn't a lot more to it
than that
so um i'm not sure i would have found it
magnus
no you would it was i mean it's it's
nice
so what is your favorite game then if i
can ask
uh i have no idea um ask me in 10
15 years okay what's your favorite game
of today that minus
um i guess the second game was uh
was nice it was sort of a uh
pretty uh it was pretty straightforward
in the sense but it's it's always
nice to play games where you follow a
plan and then
everything goes goes goes as it
as it sort of should and magnus
a bit later today we're going to see the
debut of the celebrity chess challenge
where
sal khan took on magnus age 10.
do you have any tips for future
celebrities i won't spoil how that one
went
yeah take uh take your time
and look out for tactics i was uh i was
a tricky
devil back then yeah definitely
do you have any prediction how do you
think i know you talked a little bit
with the sulcon is an incredible
scientist mathematician
do you have any prediction how do you
think he's going to do against -10
uh i think he will lose frankly but
i think it will uh will be um
will be an interesting game for uh for
sure and uh
probably uh yeah
probably quite close so finally magnus
day two quarterfinals coming up tomorrow
how will you now
make sure and avoid that you don't have
a bad second day that you sometimes had
in these knockout stages
i guess it's about being fresh and then
i think preparation for
for the first for the first black game
will be very
very important uh to set the tone for
for the rest of the day
um that's really been
my problem all right in this other
in this other day well minus we wish you
the best of luck tomorrow thank you for
joining us